great well nice to meet him nice to see
you all it's really a privilege and a
pleasure to welcome my friend Vladimir
back to the UK the conflict is a pivotal
moment Ukraine is Bravely defending
itself against Russian aggression but at
this moment it's been really good for us
to have the time to talk together in
private about the support that the UK is
giving and how we can make sure that
that support is not just here for today
but into the future as well to ensure
that Ukraine and its people Triumph not
just on the battlefield militarily but
also stand up for those values of
Freedom democracy and the rule of law
that we all hold very dear we've had
some very good conversations and
Vladimir it's great to have you here
thank you very much first of all for me
and for our team is privilege do you
host us here today Rishi and thank you
especially especially you and your
government for supporting us really at
this moment like you said at the moment
of challenges the moment for us for our
society our people especially for our
soldiers moment is
tough difficult but anyway
we need success and I'm happy that in
this way we are in way of preparing very
important counter-offensive steps you
are with us together with us
um all Great Britain you and your
government as it's very important so
thank you very much for all support of
course with uh with you know all this
best attitude to our people from your
people but of course we concentrate on
on Military Support and thank you very
much for this package that you prepared
this great huge really what can save the
lives for a lot of people thank you so
much well thanks Vladimir right we'll
take some questions yes Mr President uh
you made it very clear you need more
advanced weapons more quickly is it fair
to say that you cannot begin your new
counter-offensive until you get them and
prime minister today the criman
spokesman Dimitri peskov has warned that
Russia views the new UK military package
extremely negatively does that worry you
yes
um thank you very much for your question
we really need some some more time not
too much we'll be ready you know in some
time I I I want to be very honest with
you I I can't share with you some days I
I just don't want to prepare not not for
our friends there are no secrets from
our friends but there are some secrets
from from our neighbors that that's why
we have to to prepare and and I'm here
not only because of this support but of
course including this support it will
help us to be more strong but also to
thank you to to your people to to
government it's very very important now
when some countries not all of you know
of the world but some countries are near
with us from first days of full-scale
war and I'm thankful That's Great
Britain is one of these countries
I look it's interesting to hear from the
Kremlin what I'd say is you know Russia
is conducted an unprovoked and illegal
attack on the Ukrainian people it is
carrying out horrific war crimes and
something vladder and I have been
speaking about uh just awful treatment
of its citizens and as we said right at
the beginning the UK will remain
steadfast in supporting Ukraine and its
people to defend itself against that
aggression When Vladimir was last here
some months ago I talked then about the
provision of long-range weapons because
of the capability that they would offer
I'm pleased with the first country to be
able to do that and I'm pleased that
they will make a difference to the
defense of Ukraine and we will keep
providing support as you've seen today
with long-range offensive drones for
example more anti-aircraft and there
will be further support to come and
that's what we've been talking about
today but I think it's important for the
Kremlin to also know that we're not
going away
right we are here for the long term we
remain steadfast in wanting to defend
Ukraine not just now to reclaim its
rightful territory but also to ensure
that Ukraine has the means to defend
itself into the future as well and
that's another topic of conversation
that we've had today is about the
security Arrangements that we should put
in place amongst Allied countries for
Ukraine for the long term to ensure that
it can defend itself and provide
effective deterrence against future
Russian aggression
uh president zielinski when you were
last in the UK you made a plea for
Western fighter jets
um how are negotiations going and prime
minister where does the UK stand on that
match thank you very much today we spoke
about the Jets very important topic for
us because we can't control the sky you
know it so I think you know everything
deeply because we're real Partners who
really knows all the details what's
going on on our Battlefield thank you
very much and uh we want to create these
uh Jets Coalition and I'm very positive
with it we spoke about it and I see that
in the closest time you will hear some I
think very important decisions but we
have we have to work a little bit more
on it
yes look we we are going to be a key
part of the Coalition of countries that
provides that support to Vladimir and
Ukraine now that it is not a
straightforward thing as Vladimir and I
have been discussing to make build up
that fighter combat aircraft capability
it's not just the provision of planes
it's also the training of pilots and all
the logistics that go alongside that now
the UK can play a big part of that one
thing we will be doing starting actually
relatively soon is training of Ukrainian
pilots and that's something that we've
discussed today we're ready to implement
those plans in in relatively short order
which will mean that we're training
Ukrainian citizens to become absolutely
combat ready aircraft pilots and
particularly whether it comes to Nato
tactics as well because that's an
important part of the long-term
relationship between our countries so
we've had very good productive
discussions on that today other
countries are involved I'm talking to
those leaders I'll be doing more of that
this week in my International engagement
and we're very keen to build that
coalition of countries to give Vladimir
and his people the aircraft support that
they need
a question to president
foreign
well my Ukrainian really is nothing much
but president zielinski responding there
to a question from a Ukrainian
journalist in Ukrainian the message so
far the underlining message that we've
heard from Rishi sunak was it is
important for the Kremlin to know we are
not going away we are here for the long
term so amidst all the talk of of weapon
systems and Jets and the different kind
of diplomatic and logistical support
today or less listening to the Prime
Minister
fantastic all right thank you very much
everybody thank you very much thank you